a big [ __ ] idiot yeah who you what uh
should I interject did you was not my
intention I'm sorry
I'm sorry
we made this video
um I'm [ __ ] Matt Damon which became a
big viral video and it changed it
changed a lot it really changed the show
because suddenly celebrities wanted to
be on it which they didn't before I mean
like if you go if you ever have the
don't by the way but if you ever like go
back and watch the early shows like
there were times where
the guests weren't even paying attention
to me like they were talking to the
other guests it felt like every party I
ever was at where I'd be sitting there
at the desk and they'd be carrying a
conversation I was like uh hmm should I
interject
what's what should I do now and the show
was live and it was just a mess and we
had sometimes we had really we were
really scraping the bottom of the barrel
when it came to Stars
well you have like the sixth most
interesting person on Joe Millionaire or
something you know not even Joe we were
like all right if we have them could we
maybe get Joe they're like wow Joe's
doing Leno Joe's uh Joe's not available
but um
it's true in fact that's why I started
making fun of Matt Damon because at the
end of a show we had some terrible
guests and I was standing there I'm
wrapping up the show and I'm standing
there with these guests and I don't even
remember who they were and I go I want
to apologize to Matt Damon we ran out of
time for him and I just did it to make
our producer Jason laugh you know and he
was cracking up and uh then I just did
it again the next night and then I
started doing it all the time as just
you know
here's what I'm laughing all right
there's no way
there's no way not to be aware like when
you say yeah we're kind of scraping the
bottom of the barrel like you know when
you're looking you're looking at your
guests and you're like oh man all right
well this is this yeah and then they're
looking at their booking at my show and
going who's this have you ever gotten
like food poisoning and had to go on
stage I should have them on several
stage or did you see what I got oh my
God it almost happened at Staples Center
and once in Germany I said watch this
Joey where are we at when I [ __ ] on
myself
is ungodly it I I don't know what I ate
but I was like I literally was like if I
don't walk off this stage right now I'm
going to [ __ ] myself in front of
thousands of people and that was pretty
traumatic I was sweating it was very far
few and in between with the
opportunities for absolutely the black
woman they were only telling like a
couple stories a couple of our diverse
stories you know so you were mindful of
that at that point in time oh well
because what I kept getting from my
agents at the time is they kept saying I
was too edgy and I'm like
too edgy because you just Thug well I am
a thug yeah but I'm a trained actress
very true but you can't judge me on who
I am because that's never going to
change yeah I don't judge you on it I'm
saying I know you I'm just saying I want
you to know that I know what's in there
right yeah I know you like this you
don't you'll never let me forget like
this this you got this I got all of that
like what you what what yeah who you
what who you what what like that's
grabbing the bottle looking for the
weapon yes oh it's okay I'm working I
have a therapist okay it's called rage
I'm working on it and there are reasons
for it that's why therapy is good okay
okay we'll get there we'll get down
there we'll get down there I can't I
can't wait to get down there but at the
same time like I said and me you know
I'm 56 years old damn
I'm sorry
I'm sorry because it was a thought no no
seriously it was a thought it was a
thought and I blurted it out
I'm fine okay but just understand I
didn't mean it the way it came out we'll
take a poll on how you meant it with
people here later after the show's over
but I can sit up here and honestly say
buddy that that was from a place of Love
got it that was from like damn you
didn't if we could play it back right
now play it back these are two different
dams way back in slow motion there
wasn't no I said there was no like wow I
said damn no you said the word damn
do you want me to tell you how you said
it I know how I said it down do you want
me to say it back to you how I think you
said it go ahead damn not not true fam
not true fam I said Kevin I said damn it
each time you said it now it's gotten
quieter and quieter I could barely hear
you that last time when you said it well
that means that you can barely hear the
truth so who has the problem here
what's the problem
maybe 56 minutes the way you Nadia
Coleman each things it just flipping oh
I don't know what you just straight
around the way I'm not academic [ __ ] huh
uh-oh does he not know who that is the
way I'm not accommodation yeah he thinks
he's the only one that could not have
come and eat you
what are you talking about you don't
think I know what number coming these
kids what what is
you heard me
okay yeah
56. let's get back to it yeah still here
still kicking still walking
knees are still working no noise
right all right that's good well perfect
segue into my next question your
appetite uh
you some would refer to you
as what's it called greedy there it is
some people would say that
you're greedy uh you have put so much on
display when it comes to your love for
food the concoctions that you feel go
together uh even landed you a deal you
know a deal and the food space you had
your own meal at McDonald's
um before I get to the meal what what
what the [ __ ] is going on with your
system let's just get into the to the
meat and potatoes of it why why the
mixture of such random and and crazy
Foods
it's random yeah you put like then you
put like Cheetos and oodles and you do a
lot of a lot of crazy stuff this is how
I do it nobody showed me this but I'm
telling you okay so don't tell nobody
all right this is how I do it some days
I'm like oh really this is a close call
today well at the end of the day yes
yeah oh my god I've gone to bed at night
and been like I [ __ ] that [ __ ] up no
that was not my intention but that did
not go well cheers
you know what I mean well we can't
change that wish you could have a lot of
Shame feel a little sweaty oh God and
you know sometimes that night lasts for
a couple days yeah yeah sometimes you
know what the worst is Kevin when you do
something hold on I gotta yank this down
would you do something
public
and you just even in your mind's eye
you're like I'm just not gonna look
there yeah
I'm not don't I don't mention it it's
fine but it's gonna just don't say
anything I don't want to hear no yeah I
know I did it yeah you saw it thank you
I don't want to hear about it nope don't
want to hear about it give me a good
year then I'll look back and be like
okay you grow into certain roles I was
gonna say you're good you know what I
mean like I I couldn't have played that
10 years ago no you're good you know
what I mean like I wasn't that guy
you're you're I've seen you I'm 56. I've
seen you know don't give me that Don
Cheadle I almost did it yeah I almost
did it just now why you do that I'm the
greatest actors of our time
almost you cut me off as I was about I
was uncomfortable
I was right it was right here he's such
a cool guy I grabbed the chair because I
was going to do it with such aggression
that it was going to pull me up and I
was going to help myself balance damn
yeah yeah it's like what the [ __ ] you're
50 seconds
you're 56. now like you said okay you
wouldn't have been in a position to do
what you did but 56 is only Young when
you die at 56.
laughs laughs
[Laughter]
do you feel like you're now finally
getting a a grasp on this thing called
entertainment I have no idea what the
[ __ ] is going on ever I just I like
you're so like if your schedule I would
have a panic attack but like I just get
into cars and then get out and then do
what they say and then get back into the
car and go home but I I feel like I did
find some sort of a playing field
um where it became my thing but now I
feel like I'm at a place where like the
whole like I'm not supposed to be here
like type of like you know just
downplaying everything so hard like it's
cool to be self-deprecating like I love
it it's like my thing
but like now I'm at a place where like
I'll do other shows and like you come in
and they have stuff like written for you
and all the dialogue is like I'm a big
[ __ ] idiot hey let's smoke the Doobie
oh yeah
I'm like
like every joke is just like well you
know me I'm a big [ __ ] idiot but a
big deal [ __ ] Entourage
dude this would be great for my career I
gotta get this my manager calls me hey
they got a part this part is going to
run over about three episodes uh they
want to see you what
I remember which they want to see I
don't want to say no other names because
I don't want to hurt you that'll be
where I go oh my God I go read
a great Sheila Sheila Jeffy she [ __ ]
up I go read for Sheila she [ __ ] up oh
my God Sheila and I I come back oh I got
a call back
I come they called me back I call my
manager Dave
they want me to come back oh my God
that's a call back that's good dude you
got this you [ __ ] right I got it I'm
getting big I'm [ __ ] confident
I walk in the room
Bow Wow's in the room oh I knew it was
that part I didn't want to say because I
don't know if it's taller than you or
not the [ __ ] is Bow Wow doing here right
I'll never forget it I walk in the room
Bow Wow had on a big jersey and a do-rag
what the [ __ ] is Bow Wow doing here
this part I don't know you had a weird
Jersey nobody told me we're a Jersey
I gotta I got like a regular t-shirt God
I wish I was like the [ __ ] part is
like a fun part this guy's like loud
he's got like a little bravado to him
yeah he's got a script he's got a thing
going on are you ready for him yeah I
remember I remember
going in
I [ __ ] kill
I killed
I leave right all right man see I don't
know about why at the time all right see
you guys later I'm walking out
I don't get I'm I'm probably on the
third step walking out Bow Wow walks in
the room I hear hey
[ __ ] is going on in there
is he reading I stay on the step for a
second they're dying they're going
they're going through the roof what the
[ __ ] is happening in there
he was reading with Kevin what's
happening
yeah
uh all right well I don't get a call
back
and I keep calling and I just remember
watching Entourage and seeing Bow Wow do
the scene
and I was like I lost the part the
[ __ ] Bow Wow how big is your team you
know it's about 20 people I asked you
that question because I was gonna say
from your immediate team those are
people that really know how many people
do you have immediately yeah your
immediate team 12. yeah okay well that's
about right no 20 or 12 is a big number
that's the difference
that made a big difference but you're a
little younger than I am I'm 42. yeah
what do you I'm not going to tell you
it's on Wikipedia are you serious yeah
oh
I'm also 42 Kevin I need a white version
you need a white version I need a white
version well Kevin so as it turns out
I'm also 42. how old you can be 50 uh no
no not 50 yet
how does that what are you talking about
I thought I was gonna say something
crazy
yeah all right you're like 45 I'm in my
mid 40s 40 [ __ ] yeah there you go sure
sure you're 45 and you've had 21 years
in the life of successful TV what of
successful TV
yes uh yeah yeah I mean yeah look how
you agree with that
[Music]
[Music]